Our Guest today though is up there with
the greatest of all time in music
literally she's my favorite singer of my
generation I love her so much listing
her accolades is probably stupid because
there's so many but I'm gonna try and do
it anyway uh she says we're gonna miss
some uh she's earned three Grammy Awards
two Brit Awards and Emmy and sold over
60 million albums
her new single is so great it's called
trust fall it's out now and the album
drops February 17th so don't be stupid
go get it
um and tickets for her summer carnival
stadium tour I've seen her a couple
times a tour she's incredible you gotta
go see this they're currently on sale so
go get yes I hear you so go get your
tickets before it's too late because she
sells out y'all you I had to use money
in both times uh give it up give it up
for pink everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
I love you
thank you
plan
it's okay it's okay it's okay
we planned we planned for this time wise
we were like she's gonna come out
they're not gonna shut up because she's
incredible
um it's great to see you every how is
everything going how's everything in
your world how much time do you have
well on a whole hour for you God yeah no
I think things are good today yeah today
you Jameson is six is eleven because I
was six and eight year old they're
similar ages delicious every day is
different though some days you're like
you're wonderful and other days you're
like you're evil no I I well I mean yeah
no my kids are I think I made the best
ones that ever oh my gosh ever happened
you were a kicking they're off of the
show I'm sorry no I just finished
ridiculous young woman eat them I want
to squeeze until their heads pop off
okay me too me too but no they're fun I
mean I like a challenge though I love a
challenge my daughter thought I did too
so yeah yeah he handed me one
um well you've got your music out now so
um this is your ninth album I know isn't
that weird
it's crazy so it feels like more is that
bad to say that I mean nine feels like a
small number compared to how tired I am
that's what I was just about to say it
was like sometimes when people give me
things I'm like I feel 50. so I'm only
40. but no it does you do a lot I think
in the beginning too do you feel like
you get like in the beginning I didn't
know how to say no I knew how I didn't I
just felt like I was being
if I said no but like in the
beginning I was exhausted and I don't
remember like the first few years was
that like that for you
um I think I've been exhausted since
three lifetimes ago but I still don't
say no I I'm like I will blast someone
on Twitter make sourdough pick up my
pick up Megan from school for like seven
a.m oh my God I love that I love that I
think that's why Everyone likes you
because you're unfiltered all that so
well um every once in a while uh when we
have iconic musicians here guys on the
show much like my favorite
oh my
realization behind their music as well
as the music that inspired them um it's
a little something we call songs and
stories
on her experiences um so we're gonna go
and we're gonna take this kind of
chronologically through the stories of
our life they're excited you hear it yes
I want to talk about this You released
this song who knew in 2006 which feels
like forever
so it's about things that happen when
you're a teenager right uh it is I lost
several friends unfortunately to
overdose and
um the second one was uh very very very
very
close to me and I loved him very much
and his name was seiku but the thing
about the song that I love now after all
these years is that I never get tired of
performing it and it's taken on so many
different meanings over the years it was
about my grandmother at one point it was
about my dog it was about
I've lost people and
um so it's always sort of fresh in my
heart which kind of sucks I know yeah
but it's I need music for that though I
need music just to help me to my
feelings I can numb down really easy
hey me too so you wrote a number of
songs about your relationship with your
husband yeah still going yeah it's still
going strong and that never runs out I
know well one thank you for being amused
um for us but too like how does does it
help or hurt or both who
and I'm feeling great I feel great about
it I think well you have to take in like
Kerry's amount of feelings he can handle
and how much he is actually thinking
about the words that I'm saying or
listening at all oh yeah so I think
that's fun
I think he's fine there's one on the new
album that's um
that was a hard day and I played it for
him because it's fair he should know
what's being said about him in the world
and he just started giggling and he's
like well you're welcome and I'm like
yeah I don't need that though I don't I
don't need to write songs like this help
me not write songs like these fine I
would be flattered if I were him yeah
is it the only song ever written about
me was called Slaughter
what I was flattered what's that story I
apparently hurt this person and I chose
Carrie oh and they used the actual word
Slaughter Slaughter is a beautiful song
it's a beautiful song it's a real family
favorite around the campfire
it's amazing well one of the songs about
your relationship is please don't leave
me yes can you foreign
I love that though because I don't think
relationships are easy whatever
relationship I think relationships are
hard friendships are hard I think things
can be hard and you have to kind of take
it all especially now it's hard harder
now I think than ever but uh this song
is a little different for me outside my
wheelhouse because I'm not telling him
to leave or go away
I'm asking him to stay and that album
fun house was like my divorce record
yeah and he likes it but I was very
humbled I don't believe you was another
one I was very humbled by by being the
person that was left
and knowing it wasn't going to work but
kind of knowing that our story wasn't
finished and it was a very humbling
quiet pain as opposed to me raging and
burning and setting fire yeah but so
please don't leave me as sort of I guess
my most humble love song yeah I love it
I didn't think I was capable
you're
New York you can try all you want you're
one of those people you wear your hard
earners I do yeah and no matter what I'm
like a walking wound I know
I think you like me
if you don't care I think I don't care
kind of um no it's empathy too though I
think that you carry a lot of empathy
like for others too I think that that's
that's beautiful I think that's why all
of them were screaming and clapping for
five hours when you walked in
so you're also on tour this summer I lit
I don't know if you know this but I've
seen you like a couple times in tour
because every time I feel like you're
touring an album I'm promoting one so
like once was in Germany and once was in
Australia and I you're insane you're
like that's true probably true no I'm
I'm in the best sense of that word it is
I literally was I left like half
inspired and half wanting to quit like I
was like what like it was like you're it
was it was such a great show so like I
love it where are you going like what
are you a lot of people are joining it
too you got Brandon yeah Pat Benatar Pat
Benatar
I saw Pat Benatar sing at the when I
inducted Dolly Parton into the Hall of
Fame
um
and uh Pat Benatar saying and I was like
holy cow she sounds better now than she
ever sounded and she sounded the best
then and she's her voice is so
incredibly strong and wonderful and
she's such a badass so I'm very very
happy about that and I'm doing a couple
shows with Gwen and the script and yeah
yeah I'm so excited I love I love
performing oh my God Wayne you have
great taste like even all the artists I
love that Brandy was on there too I I
think it was really really good oh me
too I'm a big fan okay so throughout the
decades music has given a voice to the
voiceless and a song can become a huge
force behind a cause so how have you
been inspired by what you know might
call protest music because I think you
have such Empower empowering you always
have these anthems well I listen to a
lot of
um sort of
songs from the 60s my dad was a Vietnam
vet so
I was marching on Washington at three
um but also I listened to punk rock
music too and punk rock music is
question authority question everything
um and I think that
my daughter asked me the other day she
said why do you do this because I was
talking I was nailing it on Twitter and
um we've had a lot of death threats
because of irrelevant and Roe v Wade and
all the things that I speak out and
believe yeah uh strongly about and my
Willow said why do you do this and I
said because it's in me and if it's in
you you have to
and well it's important it's important
to say well it's important it's
important to put your hand behind you
and and ask someone if they need help
and it's also important to know how to
receive help and I said if it's not in
you then you can do all kinds of other
things you can donate you can vote you
can petition you can
do small things that help someone and I
said for me it's I can I'm going to die
on that mountain the one I believe on
the one I believe in
segue to what about us so it has a
greater social meaning and you can tell
in the lyrics but why what where were
you at when you were sitting down
thinking about writing that we're not
listening to each other right now and
and it's so loud and so gross and angry
and people are being forgotten people
are being counted out and and their
rights are being trampled on just
because a group of people doesn't
believe in that like I don't understand
how so many people in this world are
discounted because one group of people
decided they don't like that and I won't
I won't have it the one of the most
beautiful things that my dad taught me
was that my voice matters and I can make
a difference and I will that's an
incredible thing hello we had a young
age as well one person can change a lot
and I have no idea of the effect of your
Ripple you know I think if we all had a
chance to experience each other more it
would be a lot different I have to ask
because we both have made music before
and after having kids what do you feel
like changed do you think anything
changed oh for sure I worry so much
I was so fun
um that was so fun I was so cute
um I just I just they just break you
open you're again I was already a
walking like opened wound like please
don't hurt me I'll have to kill you and
then write about it and then the kids
came and I was like oh where do you come
from Willow brought a report card home
and her lowest grade is like a 96 and I
was like how does this feel
what are you feeling right now did you
describe it to me in order a different
level of Pride wow that must feel so
awesome so you wrote all we talked about
a little bit all I know so far I was
telling her um earlier that my daughter
and I actually listened to this on the
way to school sometimes she loves the
song I just realized I had to fix my
face I was listening so hard that I was
like I do that too and usually it's my
friend so like can you just not do this
on camera at the voice and I have no
idea I'm doing it I do that as well it's
okay whatever
um we have other really cool traits um
so what inspired all I know so far was
it Willow it was it was my kids for sure
it was I did Greatest Hits so far
because I didn't feel old enough to do
it Greatest Hits yeah and then after one
so far yeah there you go I was like you
even know exactly
um I just did all I know so far because
I the more and the older I get the less
I know and it's this is all this is what
I have to give you I have my experiences
I have you you can't unfortunately you
can't borrow my knowledge you have to
buy your own but I can at least like say
it out loud so I can say I said it yeah
I tried and my dad used to say that to
me he used to say honey throw your head
back and spit in the wind and show them
what you got yeah
yeah but when you do spit in the wind it
can come back and hit you
just things make sure make sure
something just dodged or make sure
somebody else catches it that's all I'm
saying is there a theme you feel like
that really connects this new album for
you is there like sometimes oh God that
happens for me like my next one is well
sadness and depression and divorce but
anyway good I can't wait to hear it
that's the best song what's yours about
um mine is more like the world is ending
oh so just some real uplifters for you
guys for 2023. put those are the best
songs yeah and it's also but it's also
like it's I'm still a wife and a
daughter and a mother and I lost my dad
and it's the pandemic and then my almost
dearest friend in the whole world died
eight months later and I'm still
parenting and all of these things and
and then so you write all those songs
and then you get to a point where you're
like well if we are sliding sideways off
the axis
let's dance yeah
about your first single yeah are you
incapable of not being physical as well
because you I like watch the video and
I'm like of course she's on roller
skates and like killing it and like I'm
like do you because you sing with your
whole body that's not I do like that's
what I love with my whole body too I'm
like a aggressive hummingbird
laughs
can we touch
oh my God I love aggressive hummingbirds
should be a bumper sticker
well let's talk about the title track um
off your new album trust fall trust fall
so do you believe in trust Falls would
you fall do you trust people to fall I
would catch you okay
I'll be the catcher okay I feel like
life right now is it requires getting
out of bed in the morning
um having a vagina
um dropping your kids off at school
participating in elections any of it is
requires so much trust right now yeah
and I think life is a trust fall and
those are the questions that you have to
ask is what do you fall for and what's
worth it and and having like going
through a pandemic distills down what
matters and losing your parent does that
as well and
whoo yeah I never liked it when I was a
kid
I had to go to youth camps Okay and like
we'd go and then they'd be like yeah
we're gonna do this stress well I would
always have to go to the bathroom or I
would be lying to like no I don't trust
any of your people yeah I think they're
all going to be like oh my God got you
like like that's who I was out with
Kelly I better free should talk about
this I talk a lot in therapy I'll talk
with you too you have a winery let's do
that
um
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]